We've got a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two, David p.
Here's a voicemail from an in an 18 year old
girl who I converted out of conservatism.
Take a listen.
Hi.
Um, my name is back.
I'm calling from Portis question.
Um, I made tea has and watching your show
for months now.
I grew up really Republican and I just, everything
Trump his campaign back in 2016 I was like,
where is any of the logic and this more?
And people seem to just blindly follow him.
Hmm.
I found your channel a couple months ago and
I've been watching every sense and you've
proved to be an amazing role model for me.
I don't how logical you are, how calm you
are, and you don't get fired up stopping.
And it reminds me that there is still some
rationality in this world and I've got used,
I've used a lot of the things he taught me
to be able to educate others.
So you are making a difference in disaster
duration.
I just want to let you know,
wow, what an inspirational message.
I mean, seriously, it is great that that's
the stuff that I love to hear.
Uh, because listen, I get thousands of negative
messages a day, most of them based on either
a my hair or my ethnicity or my national origin,
uh, ad hominems of all different kinds.
But that is exactly why this show exists.
And it's also why, by the way, when you say
you, what you're doing, David, is good enough
to support financially with a membership.
That's exactly what we are funding.
We are funding reaching people who aren't
in positions to pay for programs like this,
but who are actually having their lives changed
the direction of that person, of this great
young girl has now been changed as a result
of progressive, independent media from a life
of Trumpism.
I mean, come on, uh, to a life of logic
and reason and thinking critically.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Become a member.
You'll be helping people like that great color
we just heard from and you'll get access to
extra content.